i definitely don't have 4 million that's  for damn titty no no there's no way  the top streamers make a lot of money we  all know that but shroud is on another  level when it comes to flexing it  now if you want to talk about price it  is expensive for this super high-end  model it's over 10 000 bucks i got two  of those  you have this thingy to pop out some  keys and then you clean your keyboard  very easily there's a lot of food in my  keyboard currently so what i usually do  is i just get a new keyboard there has  to be over two thousand dollars and lost  there i mean they timed me out man they  [ __ ] tied me out i can't buy anymore  i'm [ __ ] timed out drought spent 13  count of private [ __ ] to do a world of  warcraft raid what well how big was this  [ __ ] contract dude only 5 000 gold  it's so expensive dude yeah but i also  have an endless bank account hold on  hold on good luck open good luck open it  up oh my god